mieux là-bas à cuba à la chute non pas
du régime mais de fidel castro le
président dictateur a manqué une marche
après un discours public
à 78 ans la moindre faiblesse la moindre
blessure relance immédiatement les
spéculations sur l'avenir de l'île après
45 ans de règne absolu
fidel castro vous allez l'entendre a
pris les devants il a voulu couper court
aux interrogations christian tu hier
soir 21h30 fin du discours de fidel
castro indices courte à peine une heure
sous l'oeil du che la routine quand
soudain l'incroyable survient la chute
de l'indéboulonnable commandant en chef
aussitôt les gardes du corps font
rempart autour de lui mais quelques
instants plus tard castro s'empare du
micro et diagnostics lui même ses
blessures fracture au genou et au bras
avant de lancer une boutade
preuve qu'il est en pleine forme
maintenant je suis très curieux de voir
les photos prises par la presse
internationale
elles feront certainement la une des
journaux demain vélo pas l'une des
photos que les cubains ne verront pas
l'incident n'a même pas été mentionné
par les médias officiels
en juin 2001 le leader cubain avait été
victime d'un malaise sans gravité lors
d'une cérémonie publique
à 78 ans fidel castro est l'un des plus
vieux dirigeant au monde encore en
exercice régnant sans partage depuis 45
ans castro l'inoxydable est sur tous les
fronts par tous les temps il a survécu à
dix présidents américains et à la
débâcle de lurs refusant d'évoquer une
quelconque retraite l'ancien guérillero
a désigné depuis longtemps un dauphin
son frère raul castro